ce n'est pas ce soir sur tf1 à mai mais
demain à 12h30 comme depuis des années
déjà d'ailleurs que vous retrouverez
danièle gilbert avec son émission midi
première tous les jours de 12 heures 30
à 13 heures sur tf1
et pour parler avec vous d'alien nous
avons invité michel lis rédacteur en
chef adjoint de télé 7 jours alors il ya
un mois je voudrais d'abord dire à
daniel que ça fait en effet huit ans et
demi que son émission existe sous des
appellations différentes qu'elle a été
pendant très longtemps surnommé notre
dame de la télévision que son succès est
encore réelle mais que nous
souhaiterions et le courrier télé 7
jours en fait foi
nous souhaiterions que cela change un
petit peu près temps la question
eh bien oui nous voulions que cette
émission qui a eu plusieurs étiquettes
plusieurs titres différents
finalement plus ça change plus c'est la
même chose et on a l'impression de
sentir une certaine lassitude de re voir
toujours les mêmes chanteurs de revoir
la même formule oh je crois que de toute
façon en matière de télévision comme
dans bien des domaines
on ne ne crée pas vraiment on reprend
toujours des idées et on passe quand il
reprend dessous d'un certain andrew dit
c'est tout à fait nouveau je comptais
dans la manière de le faire surtout la
manière de le faire je n'avais pas le
sentiment vous même d'être un peu figé
dans la façon de votre prêt de présenter
vos émissions non non c'est la coiffure
qu'ils n'aient pas changé alors aussi
elle a changé
je crois que non c'est pas tout à fait
le problème
non mais je crois que c'est un petit peu
comme dans la vie on ne
on ne change pas vraiment mais il faut
évolué c'est certain mais je pense pas
du tout être tout à fait la même chose
qu'il ya huit ans et demi mais moi
pouvons nous dire c'est assez difficile
c'est difficile moi je crois qu'il n'y a
rien de pire que l'indifférence de toute
façon ce que je voudrais vous dire aussi
daniel c'est beaucoup de on parle
beaucoup actuellement des problèmes dans
la chanson et dans le show business
beaucoup de chanteurs ceux bien sûr qui
ne passe pas chez vous se plaignent de
trouver un barrage auprès de mes dix
premières ça m'étonnerait car vraiment
au nous nous passons toutes sortes de
chanteurs sans aucune distinction du
goût personnel
tout le monde peut passer pouvez-vous
leur expliquer comment il faut faire
alors enfin c'est très simple c'est
comme dans toutes les émissions c'est
très banal
il faut tout simplement envoyer le
disque ou une bande parce que on ne
passe pas forcément parce qu'on a
enregistré un disque que nous passons
aux sites et des chanteurs qui n'ont pas
enregistré de disque est tout simplement
parce que c'est joli parce que on a eu
une sorte de petit coup au coeur et de
deux coups de foudre pour ce qu'ils font
l'autre jour c'était la semaine dernière
une jeune fille est venue nous voir et
avec sa guitare elle venait de hollande
est venu sur le plateau elle a dit voilà
on m'a dit que je devais venir vous voir
je voudrais bien vous proposer une
chanson alors elle l'a elle l'a
interprété comme ça au milieu d'eux du
branle-bas de combat pendant la
répétition de l'émission c'était joli
elle a une très jolie voix
je ne sais pas si elle deviendra une
vedette n'a aucune importance était un
agréable moment à passer en écoutant
elle est passée dans l'émission ça c'est
un coup de coeur
donc quand même vous choisissez ont
choisi il ya 25 minutes par jour ce qui
est ce qui est colossal ce qui est un
cadeau fantastique permanent pendant six
jours de la semaine sur 7
il faut bien quand même choisir vos
principaux concurrents étaient jusqu'à
maintenant les jeux radiophoniques
puisque vous passez à l'heure où sont
ces jeux qui passent sur les radios les
radios périphériques mais radio
nationale
évidemment mais à partir de septembre 77
la situation va changer puisque la
chaîne voisine c'est à dire antenne 2
qu'on peut citer sur tf1 en pleine
d'humanisme bien sûr va avoir à son tour
une émission qui démarrera pendant la
vôtre c'est très bien alors avez vous
l'intention à 7
à ce moment là de de faire évoluer les
midis première
de la modifier un petit peu eh bien nous
verrons à ce moment-là rendez-vous
septembre rendez vous en septembre ça ne
vous fait pas peur à pas du tout d'un
calme olympien est la déraison
merci michel lis merci daniel d'être
venu nous parler un petit peu
aujourd'hui de midi première que nous
regarderons bien sûr comme chaque jour à
12h30 sothea femmes au revoir